geschätzte medienvertreter werte damen
und herren nicht dass sie recht herzlich
zur pressekonferenz miliz bericht 2020
begrüßen am podium bundesminister tanna
und der miliz beauftragte generalmajor
erwin hameseder generalmajor ich darf
mir statement litten sehr verehrte frau
bundesminister meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren die carrera-bahn gemimt
hat unser land nach wie vor leider fest
im griff
aber die krise hat eines sehr deutlich
gemacht
österreich kann sich auf sein bundesheer
verlassen und das bundesheer kann sich
auf die miliz verlassen
die erfahrungen die wir in den letzten
zwölf monaten gemacht haben vor der
bundesminister sind sehr sehr wertvoll
eines ist auch klar die politische
entscheidung die getroffen wurde das
erstmalig die miliz zum einsatz
durch den einsatz präsenzdienst gerufen
wurde
das ist wahrlich ein historischer
meilenstein und damit wurde auch sehr
klar dass die miliz eine unverzichtbare
säule für das österreichische bundesheer
ist und noch wichtiger ist aber für mich
als mit beauftragter direkt für die frau
bundesminister sein darf werte ich die
unterstützungsleistungen die miliz in
dieser pandemie aber jetzt auch darüber
hinaus im jahr 2020 geleistet hat als
sehr großen erfolg
es gibt gewisse einschränkungen zu denen
werde ich aber noch kommen aber die
qualität die leistungen und die
motivationslage
unserer mit zutaten und milizsoldaten
waren und sind herausragend und was es
auch gegeben hat und dieses auch
einzigartig
es hat einen festen schulterschluss
gegeben zwischen dem militär und den
berufssoldaten und soldatinnen das war
es ja deutlich spürbar
das ist ein kultureller wandel der durch
das österreichische bundesheer durch
geht und trotz der hohen befreiungs
raten war das österreichische bundesheer
in der lage die gestellten aufgaben und
anforderungen unter einsatz der miliz
voll und ganz zu erfüllen und die
erwartungen der österreichischen
bevölkerung voll und ganz
auch nicht zu enttäuschen sondern ganz
im gegenteil der bevölkerung vorzuführen
dass dieses milizsystem lebt die größte
herausforderung die wir aber haben für
eine planungs konforme materielle
ausrüstung aller verbänden einheiten des
österreichischen bundesheers ist der
investitionsrückstau meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren eine
investitionsrückstau der sich über 15
jahre hinweg aufgebaut hat und praktisch
alle bereiche und waffengattungen und
damit ganz wesentlich unsere militanten
und milizsoldaten betrifft
hier gibt es noch sehr viel zu tun und
ich weiß dass die frau bundesministerin
ganz vorne eine stark verbündete für die
miliz ist und dafür frau
bundesministerin möchte ich mich sehr
herzlich bedanken
eine tolle zusammenarbeit und trotz der
vielen vielen aufgaben die du hast
freuen sich die milizsoldaten immer dann
wenn du sie auch im einsatz besucht das
ist eine großartige wertschätzung um
ihnen meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren auch einen ausblick zu geben als
miliz beauftragter ist es mir in diesem
jahr
ein besonderes anliegen die miliz
weiterzuentwickeln und die
rahmenbedingungen zu optimieren
ich komme aus einer unternehmensgruppe
wie die meisten von ihnen wissen und
daher ist es mir ein besonderes anliegen
die verbindung zwischen den soldat sein
also milizsoldaten milito tat zum
arbeitgeber in die wirtschaftswelt
hinzuweisen und diese verbindung zu
stärken
ich muss aber leider gottes auch
einräumen dass in der arbeitswelt auf
breiter basis noch immer das
grundsätzliche verständnis für miliz
tätigkeiten fehlt da haben wir noch viel
viel zu tun
und natürlich hat das auch mit der
veränderung der arbeitswelt insgesamt zu
tun
ganz besonders natürlich in krisenhaften
situationen
es gibt keine zweifel der druck auf
arbeitgeber und arbeitnehmer ist
insgesamt enorm gestiegen und trotzdem
werde ich nicht müde werden zu erklären
welche vorteile menschen mit sich
bringen die eine miliz funktion haben
und als arbeitgeber tätig ist der anteil
der medizin und pflichtigen bei den
erwerbstätigen beträgt 0,4 prozent und
das ist mit ein grund warum die miliz
normalerweise im täglichen leben in der
arbeitswelt nicht tatsächlich so
auffällt im wahrsten sinn des wortes sei
eine sehr niedrige wahrnehmungsschwelle
und daher fällt bei den arbeitgebern
oftmals das verständnis der erworbenen
militärischen qualifikationen für den
arbeitsmarkt
und mit dem blick in dem zukunft halte
ich es für sehr entscheidend dass die
wirtschaft sichtbar und messbar und was
sind wir auf einem guten weg die miliz
tätigkeiten letztlich auch zum vorteil
für den betrieb sieht zum beispiel im
betrieblichen krisen management und
dadurch entsteht dann eine gegenseitige
akzeptanz
und das verständnis der arbeitgeberseite
für unser system wo es einfach
milizübungen braucht aber auch natürlich
das verständnis für einen allfälligen
einsatz präsenzdienst der zu leisten ist
und wir auch im letzten jahr geleistet
worden ist ja der bürger in uniform und
das ist die miliz muss üben und sich
auch weiterbilden dafür sind die
voraussetzungen zu schaffen zum beispiel
es sollten ausbildungszeiten anrechenbar
sein und anrechenbar werden ein
bildungskonto für kaba funktionen solche
durchlässigkeit zwischen bundeswehr und
wirtschaft stärken zum beiderseitigen
nutzen
und ich denke hier vor allem daran dass
die beim militär erworbenen
qualifikationen zertifiziert werden von
der zivilen wirtschaft zertifiziert
werden und damit nutzbare tucson in der
wirtschaft eins zu eins zur anwendung
gelangen können damit spart sich david
geber zeit aber auch geld bei der
ausbildung von führungskräften und wir
haben erfreulicherweise die
unterstützung des
wirtschaftskammerpräsidenten tochter
mara und es sollte uns gelingen dass wir
in diesem jahr hier relevante
fortschritte machen können und wir
werden pilotprojekte mit einzelnen
unternehmungen ins leben rufen
ein wesentliches thema das ich heute
auch anspreche die stärkung der miliz
durchweg falls sozialrechtlicher
nachteile dieses vorhaben steht auf der
agenda ganz oben
denn wie sie benutzt sie erwähnten damen
und herren wissen es hat am 29 05 einen
entschließungsantrag einstimmig
beschlossen gegeben im parlament und es
kann doch nicht sein dass jemand der
mehr als sonst üblich für die republik
österreich tut dann für diesen dienst
sozialversicherungsrechtliche nachteile
und auch finanzielle nachteile erleidet
das gegenteil es sollte wohl der fall
sein wie auch in der schweiz das hier
ein anderes system geschaffen wird nur
so können wir in zukunft auch junge
staatsbürgerinnen und staatsbürger für
unsere miliz gewinnen
es kann und darf nicht mehr soziale
härten für milizsoldaten geben und
einschränkungen beim
kinderbetreuungsgeld beim familien
zeitbonus und insbesondere
nichtanrechnung von wer dienstleistungen
für die pension das muss hoffentlich
dann ab heuer dann der vergangenheit
angehören
und bei der besoldung und da bin ich
dafür der bundesminister sehr sehr
dankbar das sind wir absolut schon am
richtigen weg und wenn wir die miliz
verbessern wollen dann haben wir
einerseits den status quo zu beurteilen
die erfahrungen aus dem jahr 2020 mit in
die zukunft hinein zu nehmen und der
wärme ganz wesentliche fortschritte
machen und jetzt bin ich bei den
fortschritten die gemacht wurden und das
wäre ohne die frau bundesminister nicht
möglich gewesen nämlich die umsetzung
des 200 millionen euro seien die invest
ag das führt die miliz das ist etwas
völlig herausragendes hat es in dieser
form noch nicht gegeben
und das sind themen dieses gerät die
mobilität kommen die verbesserung
kommunikations und nachsicht fähigkeit
das kommt unmittelbar bei unseren
mitgliedsverbänden an und dafür bin ich
sehr dankbar denn eine zeitgemäße
ausrüstung und ausstattung gehört dazu
aus sicherheitsgründen dazu ist aber
auch eine ganz wichtige ist ein
wichtiger motivationsfaktor
wir haben ein informations modul miliz
gegründet zur sicherstellung der
informations aktualität und wir haben
hier eine tolle informationsdrehscheibe
gegründet
die neue maßstäbe setzt und zu guter
letzt gab es tolle fortschritte auch bei
der ausbildung es wurde die karte
ausbildung neu gestaltet die unter
offiziersausbildung wieder modular
eingeführt und das sind themen die uns
unzweifelhaft dazu bringen werden dass
wir die miliz und unsere dahinter
stehend milizsoldaten ganz wesentlich
begeistern können damit sie jederzeit
bereit sind in einen einsatz
präsenzdienst zu gehen wir müssen also
dranbleiben bald diesen themen nicht
alle maßnahmen kosten immer geld sondern
es geht darum innovationen auf sich zu
überlegen prozesse zu vereinheitlichen
zu vereinfachen und schon führt das zu
einem ganz anderen motivation stand der
sowieso schon sehr hoch ist sehr geehrte
frau bundesministerin
ich darf mich sehr herzlich für die
tolle zusammenarbeit bedanken für das
vertrauen bedanken die du in unserem
milizsoldaten setzt aber auch in mich
und ich kann dir versprechen dass ich
weiterhin voll dich unterstützen werde
wo es mir nur irgendwie möglich ist
vielen dank danke
generalmajor frau bundesministerin ich
da von mir statement ersuchen
sehr geehrter herr miliz beauftragte
generalmajor sehr geehrte damen und
herren das österreichische bundesheer
ist nach den grundsätzen eines
milizsystems einzurichten
das sagt uns der artikel 79 der
österreichischen bundesverfassung
jahrzehntelang wurde
dies aber vergessen jahrzehnte lang
wurde ohne zweifel unsere miliz
stiefmütterlich behandelt ich bin daher
sehr froh und dankbar dass ich mit
unserem medizin beauftragt
der general war seit jahren einen
kämpfer an der seite habe für eine
starke miliz und dass wir hier gemeinsam
im vergangenen jahr ohne zweifel eine
trendwende erreichen konnten die wir
auch im heurigen jahr fortsetzen werden
ja und wie wichtig das ist sehr geehrte
damen und herren das hat uns das
vergangene jahr gezeigt das tut es jetzt
noch der generalmajor hat sein
gesprochen wir mussten erstmals in der
geschichte der republik zu beginn für
carola krise die miliz aufbieten
ja nun dass auch an dieser stelle ein
für alle mal klarzustellen wir haben
nicht zwei monate für die aufbietung
gebraucht weil es nicht schneller ging
nein das war ein zwei stufen plan bei
dem wir eine andere maßnahme
vorgeschoben haben den aufschub
präsenzdienst sie erinnern sich
wir mussten 2000 junge männer die
abgerüstet hätten im märz um zwei monate
verlängert
diese wurden dann durch die miliz
abgelöst das nennt man einsatz und
ressourcenplanung aber sei es wie es sei
dass diese maßnahme sehr geehrte damen
und herren goldrichtig war das haben wir
bewiesen dass unsere miliz für uns da
ist wenn wir sie brauchen und es ist mir
ein bedürfnis bei dieser militärauftrag
der danke zu sagen mich aber auch bei
allen soldatinnen und soldaten zu
bedanken die bei dieser aufbietung ihre
unverzichtbaren beitrag geleistet haben
aber nicht nur bei der aufbietung main
das ganze jahr über ist unsere miliz im
einsatz sei es im assistenzeinsatz oder
ganz besonders stark im auslandseinsatz
überall da wo unser heer im einsatz ist
da stecken auch zu einem gewissen anteil
mit soldatinnen und soldaten in
uniformen alleine im inland sind es
diese woche rund 900 das ist gut so und
ich kann es auch hier nochmals
klarstellen ohne miliz ginge es nicht
die ausbildung und die starke einbindung
der miliz in der krisenbewältigung war
ein wichtiger und richtiger schritt der
uns auch einen blick auf die
herausforderungen auf die probleme des
systems offenbart hat ich möchte hier
auf die drei wichtigsten punkte noch
einmal eingehen
das eine ist budget und ausrüstung das
zweite die ausbildung und das dritte die
personalgewinnung zum budget im
vergangenen jahr durften wir ja
gemeinsam das erste miliz paket in der
höhe von 200 millionen euro verkünden
ein paket mit dem wir nun die
dringendsten beschaffungen durchführen
und daher gerne reimer angesprochen das
ist insbesondere im bereich der
mobilität die fahrzeuge mobilität der
truppe die bewaffnung auch die mannes
ausrüstung und erste teile sind bereits
im zulauf und die ersten maßnahmen die
werden jetzt auch bereits spürbaren zum
zweiten zur ausbildung das system der
kader anwärter ausbildung war für die
milizsoldaten die die laufbahn zum
unteroffizier nachholen wollten in
wahrheit untauglich er sagte mir
eigentlich der gesunde menschenverstand
schon das 13 monate kurs am stück für
wohl nur die wenigsten milizsoldaten die
mieten
zivilen berufsleben stehen machbar ist
und daher freue ich mich wirklich sehr
freuen wir uns sehr dass wir die
modulare und offiziers ausbildung
einführen konnten die auf 61 bis
zweiwöchigen modulen besteht ja dass das
die richtige maßnahme ist das zeigen uns
auch der erfreulich hohen anmeldezahlen
und wir können uns jetzt schon freuen
wenn wir die ersten absolventen dann
nächstes jahr in ein sams wachtmeister
willkommen heißen dürfen zum dritten zur
personalgewinnung in den letzten jahren
wurde das problem der fehlenden
freiwilligen meldungen immer größer
besonders chargen und und offiziere
fehlten sie fehlten in den kompanien wir
haben dieses problem nun einer lösung
zugeführt und diese bereits
implementiert das programm heißt meint
dienst für österreich und mit dem wollen
wir abhilfe schaffen
was heißt es alle grund wird ihnen die
sich für eine 30 tägige miliz
verpflichtung die innerhalb von zehn
jahren abzuleisten ist melden bekommen
bereits ab dem dritten monat 400 euro
zum ihrem soll dazu machen sie dann
zusätzlich den ersten teil der unter
offiziersausbildung ebenso in ihren
grundwehrdienst da bekommen sie nochmals
monatlich 200 euro dazu ja und wenn sie
sich für einen drei- bis sechsmonatigen
assistenzeinsatz nach dem
grundwehrdienst melden
dann erhalten sie immer seine äußerst
große finanzielle ein großes
finanzielles plus und dazu kommt dann ja
auch noch dass die meldung zum
assistenzeinsatz einer meldung zur miliz
gleichkommt vieles ist schon geschehen
aber wir haben in allen diesen drei
bereit
vor weitere maßnahmen zu setzen und so
die miliz stärker denn je zu machen
die miliz soldatinnen und soldaten sie
sind so sagt unser miliz beauftragt er
immer die bürger in uniform sie sind
lehrerinnen ärzte tischler chemikerinnen
und vieles mehr
und jeder arbeitgeber und jede
arbeitgeberin kann stolz und froh sein
wenn sie mit soldatinnen soldaten als
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter haben
dankeschön dankeschön frau
bundesministerin werte damen und herren
wir die medienvertreter ich darf sie
jetzt im anschluss um ihre fragen bieten
bitte den namen und das medium und etwas
warten bis das mikrofon bei ihnen ist
bitteschön markus wiemann von der abwehr
genial wir haben sie das haben sie schon
angesprochen das besoldungssystem dass
es da gespräche gibt wie weit sind dann
die gewinn seit dem letzten jahre
da gab es differenzen leider nicht
verstanden das besoldungssystem für die
miliz wie weit sind die gespräche
gediehen dass man das vereinheitlicht am
parlamentarischen weg dank der frau
bundesminister die vorstellungen sind
klar im einsatz eine weitgehende
angleichung in den funktionen egal ob
jemand der berufssoldat ist oder auch
als einsatz präsenzdiener miliz soldat
ist dankeschön
das gibt es sonst noch fragen wenn es
keine fragen mehr gibt dann danke für
ihr kommen die pressekonferenz ist
beendet
dankeschön